back in the old days
this part of the world used to be the
economic superpower
of the planet there were dynasties that
discovered everything from the compass
to printing to making paper to gunpowder
they would lead
huge expeditions around the globe this
was
china the middle kingdom and right next
door india
this was the center of the global
economic universe
but around the 1800s that started
changing
over here in europe and the united
states there was a major
revolution that started taking place
science then machines then weapons
trains cars flight bombs
factories cities and with their new
power these countries
started to expand to take over large
swaths of the map
china remained a great civilization but
as the west
started showing up knocking on china's
door with their big
guns china couldn't really match their
firepower
and they had to concede land to britain
which is how we got hong kong
the industrial revolution didn't really
happen in china the same way it did in
the west
and by the middle of the 1800s china
began a massive decline
in its economic standing in the world a
century later that situation got way
worse
as china was invaded by its neighbor
japan china's economy was no longer the
prosperous middle kingdom
but rather a shadow of itself a poor
country that was being occupied by
outsiders
once world war ii was over the west
devised a new global economic and
financial system
it was modeled after the economic system
that was working so well in the west
capitalism free enterprise still with
some government oversight
and high taxes for the rich and
corporations but it was still capitalism
and after the war this capitalism would
go on to become
a miracle for many countries rebuilding
germany
france japan for many in the west
post-world war ii capitalism was like a
magic
elixir that was fixing everything it was
working so well that
more and more people started to believe
that we needed to get government
out of capitalism and let the market
just do its thing
one of the major advocates for this idea
of unfettered capitalism
was this guy never in history been a
more effective machine for eliminating
poverty than the free enterprise system
in the free market
a chicago-based economist named milton
friedman
if they fail they bear the cost if they
succeed
they get the benefit the idea at the
core
of this financial and economic system
was that
companies would get investment from
people who own shares in that company we
call this a corporation
and that the sole purpose of this
corporation was to make money
for these owners or these shareholders
in milton friedman's own words
quote the social responsibility of a
business
is to increase profits that is the role
of a business
increasing short-term gains for
shareholders
would benefit all of society according
to this model
and if you look at the data in the
united states and the west
milton friedman sort of had a point
and it led to huge prosperity in the
west
as the u.s economy exploded
wait a minute but what about china are
we talking about china and its economy
you know
the middle kingdom china so while the
u.s and western economies are thriving
because of this corporate
free market capitalism that was taking
over the world china was descending
further and further into decline instead
of joining the capitalism party that the
west was spreading throughout the world
china resisted turning to a one-party
rule
communist system headed by this guy
mao zedong who destroyed any chance
of china's economy ever joining the
prosperity happening around the world
by the 1970s china was a place of
widespread poverty
the once prosperous kingdom had reached
rock bottom
but that was all about to change
so it's the 1970s and this is china's
new leader
deng zhao ping he came into power
hoping to turn around this 150 years
of humiliation in china the decline of
china as a superpower elsewhere in the
region china's neighbors
had economies that joined the global
economic party that was happening
in capitalism and they were thriving
they saw immense
economic miracles and pulled millions
out of poverty deng
specifically went on a visit to
singapore early on in his term
where ethnic chinese had adopted the
free market
and they were thriving he felt inspired
the maoist economic doctrine that had
failed
was over and it was time to see if china
could rebuild its economy
experimenting with some version of
capitalism but he had to do this
carefully so as not to disrupt the
one-party rule that china had created so
he decided to just focus on
one little village a sleepy village in
southern china
of just around 30 000 people right
across the border from the british
controlled hong kong
which at the time was thriving because
of its hardcore capitalistic economy
deng xiaoping designated this little
town as
quote a special economic zone where
foreign companies could set up
and invest in a very capitalistic
free market hong kong would sort of act
as a bridge
between western businesses and this
little gateway
into communist china it was still
socialism but with some
chinese capitalistic characteristics
what happens next is arguably the most
mind-blowing economic miracle ever to
have taken place
on planet earth
this little sleepy village that was a
special economic zone in china
exploded from a little fishing village
with
a little more than a few thousand people
and some rice paddies to a massive
city of over 10 million people the
average income went from one dollar a
day
to over thirty thousand dollars a year
this starts happening all over china and
meanwhile
milton friedman's back in the us being
like
yep told ya soon there were a bunch of
cities designated in china
for special economic activity or
basically capitalism in a socialist
country
and more and more foreign companies
flocked to china
for its cheap labor it became the
world's factory
china joined this trend of other asian
economies
and eventually passed them up to become
the second largest economy
on earth you can see this in a graph
this year asia will actually
pass the rest of the world in accounting
for more than 50
of global gdp it is a massive economic
transformation
and it explains why china has become so
powerful
okay but wait this is a very wonderful
story about capitalism and its ability
to lift millions of people out of
poverty
and to industrialize a country seemingly
overnight
but there's another side to this coin
that we need to talk about
i have two graphs i want to show you
they look like this okay let's look at
this one
first it's called the elephant graph do
you sort of see why
let's deconstruct this graph and try to
understand
what this says about the past 30 years
of the rise of china
on this axis is everyone on earth
ranked by their income grouped into
percentiles
so these people down here make an income
that is the 10th
percentile the lowest 10 in the world
and then the 20th percentile
and so on and so on up to these people
up here who are the richest in the world
they
have an income that puts them in the
90th percentile this axis here
shows how much growth in income these
people have had
over the past 35 years basically during
the heyday of
shareholder capitalism and the rise of
china so you'll see how this plays out
in just a second
let's start plotting how much income
growth each of these
groups saw over the past 35 years the
bottom 10 percent
saw their incomes grow by around 75
not bad these are people who live in the
poorest countries
who make the lowest income in the world
the 20 to 30 percentile
saw a huge growth in their income 125
percent and more over the past 35 years
this is like the new middle class
in china and other asian countries who
saw huge income
growth due to globalization they did
really well under this system
but then you start to get to the people
in the 50th and 60th and 70th and 80th
percentile
this is basically people who live in the
middle class in the west
their incomes have grown much slower
sometimes under 50 percent over the
course of 35 years which is
little over one percent a year not very
much income growth
and some of these people in the west
have seen their incomes shrink
like the blue-collar workers in detroit
and the rust belt whose jobs disappeared
to china
so so far you can sort of see why this
makes sense
the people in china who benefited from
this mass industrialization
saw huge benefits and the people here in
the united states and in the west
who saw jobs go overseas to china
saw a way slower growth in their income
but watch what happens next
when we get to the groups of people who
are at the 99
percentile basically the richest 1
in the world and for this i actually
have to stretch out the graph to get us
a little bit more granular
these are the people who have the
highest incomes in the world let's see
how
their income has grown over the past
35 years you can see that their income
has
exploded under this system they're
seeing
tripling of their income in the past 35
years
now a reminder that this is 35 years of
data from every economy on earth
this shows everyone on the planet so
this gives us a view of who
are the winners and the losers of this
shareholder capitalism that has
globalized to asia and around the world
the top 1 of income earners
saw the biggest benefits from this
system they are the ones who
disproportionately benefit
from shareholder capitalism and the
growth of globalization
okay so that's my first graph it's the
elephant graph
it is a very useful way to see one of
the results
of this version of capitalism and the
growth of china
the second graph looks like this
this shows the amount of co2 emissions
by country
you've got europe in the united states
and then up here you've got
china the world's largest emitter of co2
like the elephant graph this graph
combines loads of data to show us
that shareholder capitalism focuses so
much on short-term
profits for shareholders that it leaves
out any consideration
for how this economic activity affects
the planet we live on
and our ability to live on it i know
you've heard this message a bunch
and if you're like me it is hard to not
become sort of
numb to this impending crisis that we
don't really know what it looks like and
it feels like there's nothing we can do
but we have to do everything really
quickly
but let me just reiterate in my own
words that it is now
a certain fact that our global climate
is
changing in such a way that it will
very likely lead to immense shifts on
our
earth and our ability to live on our
earth it's already happening
it will continue to happen and
all we can do now is maybe put on the
brakes a little bit
[Music]
okay let me just wrap this up and give
you my final thought on what this all
means
i'm not showing you all these graphs
because i'm just like a data nerd who
loves to look at graphs although
i kind of am sorry i'm showing you these
graphs because the story of the rise of
china is often a story of how capitalism
has pulled
tens and hundreds of millions of people
out of poverty and it has and that's
amazing
but these graphs give us a view
of what it has also done what this
version of capitalism
also incentivizes and results in if
we're going to consider the effects
of this version of capitalism we have to
look at
all of its effects not just some of them
so what's the solution
is it socialism no it's not
it is simply a new version of capitalism
a reframing of how we think about
business and globalization one that old
milton friedman
would despise and one that more and more
businesses are
actually realizing we must adopt the
solution isn't to scrap capitalism
altogether
but instead to expand it to not just
focus on
shareholders and delivering them
short-term profits as quickly and as
efficiently as possible
but to also focus on other people who
are affected
by the business you can call these
stakeholders
this is like the customers and the
suppliers and the employees and the
government and the overall economy and
the planet and of course shareholders
this is called stakeholder capitalism
and it's basically just an
acknowledgement
that businesses that focus only on
profits for shareholders
don't end up benefiting everyone there
are winners and losers
it's not good for a huge swath of the
population
nor for the changing climate oh and by
the way this isn't some fringe liberal
idea
some of the biggest companies here in
the united states like walmart apple
jpmorgan have signed on to adopting a
new model
of capitalism this is changing and in
the next five to ten years
i believe we will see a new version of
how businesses interact in the economy
so you're probably wondering listen i
clicked on a video about the rise of
china and we're ending here with
stakeholder capitalism
the rise of china is a story of
capitalism
a certain version of capitalism it's a
story about how
capitalism can morph and change
depending on what
effects we want businesses to play in
our society
if we want to produce the most amount of
wealth in the most efficient way
then the old shareholder model actually
really works well for that
but if you want businesses to benefit
everyone including our children
and our grandchildren and their ability
to live on this planet then our
capitalism
needs to pull in more priorities than
just profits for shareholders
what may be right for one stage in the
development of an economy may not be
right for another stage
the so-called greenhouse effect is
created by carbon dioxide a colorless
odorless gas
so i got to dig through a lot of data
for this video
and i was able to partner with the world
economic forum
which is a think tank that i respect
they actually pioneered this idea of
stakeholder capitalism decades ago
well before apple and walmart realized
that it was a good idea
the head of the world economic forum
just launched a book
called literally stakeholder capitalism
it's an in-depth
look at not only the rise of asia and
china but also other major trends that
help us understand the need to upgrade
our capitalism
the book is really good it's packed with
useful information and graphics
it's easy to read and to comprehend i'm
going to put a link in the description
where you can learn more
it is available for you to purchase now
if you want to get a deeper look
into the future of our economy thank you
world economic forum for
partnering with me on this video uh the
davos summit happened this week
and um i'm really glad that i was able
to
be a part of it so hope you're all doing
well
having a good year so far 2021
there's a new president down the road
and it's kind of exciting and i'll see
you in the next one